boom hello everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin and
we're today we're sitting down Lisa
becak wah hello thank you so much for
coming thank you very much I'm really
excited for this me too
should be fun let's do this what's your
superpower I love that title word that's
the big question yeah it's like the
essence of every being yeah I think it's
one of the most important things in a
world where we're often thinking in
terms of what can we do better or what's
wrong and framing things in the negative
it's a really powerful place to say
what's the thing that you have strengths
and what's the the place that you are
the most skilled and where can you put
that and how can you put that everywhere
in your life yeah let it be your driver
yeah it's like kind of like self
actualization yeah I think it's
definitely a huge part of
self-actualization there's so much more
to it as you know because that's such a
big exploration for you yeah and and and
as well yeah so so you host the
superpower you podcast I do it's it's a
show that I launched December 14th I'm
an episode 18 and they're long-form
interviews with amazing people some of
whom I know from this incredible
environment that we share here in the
Bay Area and others who I either come
across in a day to day life and and
others I seek out because they're very
well known mostly they're experts in
their fields if not well known some are
are also known and we dig into that
skill set that I call a superpower which
is the ability or the inclination that
you've had all your life no matter which
incarnation of your life you've been in
that it shows up everywhere you go and
the interesting thing about superpowers
is that not everyone knows what their
superpower is because it's that strength
that is so natural to us that it's
almost like the water we swim in and the
air we breathe yes
so a lot of times people have to ask
other people to reflect back their
superpower and
they do it seems natural and clicks in
and makes sense
and often that happens in my show where
I'll see this person super ya know I
mention it and they'll say wow you're
right yeah
and in general we need to get better at
asking people really thought-provoking
questions and deeper questions about
their own journey and spirit and what
they care about in the world and by
doing so we can unlock that voice for
their superpower you know it's
interesting that you say that because
one of the themes I've seen come up over
and over again in interviewing people is
that very thing that if we can stay
regardless of the situation in our lives
and with other people curious then we
can ask those kind of profound questions
that do you know create the tenor of our
lives and do give us the strength to be
in the kind of connection that we want
to be with people and I did see one of
your interviews that I loved that
mentioned that truth that the quality of
our lives is the quality of our
questions and I see that coming up over
and over again in the conversations I
have with people many because a lot of
times I'm asking people how do we live
an effective life and and it's one of
those themes that keeps coming up is
that asking powerful questions that
allow people to be authentically
themselves is the way to create
community it's the way to be in a
pregnant in your own presence it's the
way to help other people recognize their
strengths and also experience their
authentic self in that moment and it's
also just I think like you mentioned in
that piece that I'm talking about it's a
great neck networking skill because when
you've become curious about someone and
asked a powerful question that's about
the authentic self and especially the
authentic self in its best light you you
endear yourself to people because you've
actually contributed something to them
and if you can contribute something to
another person then they're gonna be
thrilled to be around you so so that's
definitely one of the things I want to
ask you since about since and I don't
know I know you were going to talk about
all different things but yeah go ahead
and come my way [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know you've done so many to
interviews and you've done a lot of
thinking about questions to you what
what what is one of the things that you
see as being a quality of a powerful
question I already mentioned that and I
kind of am writing on something that you
said in that video which is that if you
can ask a question that allows a person
to share something that's personal to
them then that's a good question but is
there anything else that comes to mind
as a question that serves in an
interview process in an interview
situation or just in life it's a good
question really good okay so what what
classifies a quality question and say
that what classifies a quality question
what what has served you well in
interviewing people so a quality
question we talked about it a little bit
where we said that it is important for
the question to inspire something
powerful from within the other person
it's also important for me to ask
questions that are non-binary yes so we
we think very much so like a transistor
on or off as though we're processing all
of this data and information through our
perception and then we go immigration on
or off healthcare on or off and so
that's creating a major polarization and
if we just enjoy the nuance to all these
complex multivariate conversations then
we in state quantum as' stay even keel
we're not going hyper super excitable
all the time about every single news
points or like super duper negative and
emotional about these points as well but
we're just you know relaxed and we're
able to just peacefully chat about it
yeah then I think we can really
understand
the complexity of that middle ground and
then maybe find things like what are the
top five most important aspects of
immigration that we should figure out
how to discuss rather than good or bad
and on or off so that and then I love
the ability to say I don't know and we
actually get a lot of people on the show
just saying you know I don't know and
then we usually follow up by just saying
you know what do you think then yeah
what do you think because it's totally
okay to say don't know it's very
empowering to say I don't know those are
some of the things I would say another
thing is very very abstract societal
driving questions for example it's a
it's abstract to think about wealth
inequality a little bit abstract
besides you walk down Market Street you
see fifty percent of people are on the
street and fifty percent of people are
techies lead more leader people and so
you see like whoa huge wealth dichotomy
huge at the same time it's a little more
abstract to think of people that have
billions of dollars and people that live
on less than a dollar a day very
abstract but let's think about that that
exists in the world then the next
question is information technology and
biotechnology neural prosthetics AI in
robotics
space colonization all these things are
sort of cryptocurrencies are slowly
launching and the rich have immediate
access to it faster than the poor do so
now the next kind of this is one of the
things that I asked about on the show a
lot is is what do we do about that gap
that wealth gap because again this is a
again I asked about this question
because it's a pressing question that
faces society right now I think in top
questions artificial general
intelligence being an existential threat
to humanity and then the second one is
wealth inequality class causing a
class-based speciation yeah being these
top two societal driving questions the
that I asked about so I want to go back
a little bit so you reflect back what I
think you're saying that I think is
really interesting because I love the
way you think you're going
on all different kind of you know
tentacles to the idea which is super
exciting and I think also reflects what
you're saying which is that a question a
good question is a big question a good
question is a question that allows for
multiple layers of answer and for for
multiple nuanced ways of thinking and
might just be big enough that the
correct answer is I don't know because
then we're in a generative conversation
right and so that's that's super cool
and and and I love it and then you
started to go off on something else that
I think is really interesting and you
just implied it was implicit but it
sounds to me like one of your ways of
thinking about questions includes the
opportunity to not just you're not
seeing it as a superpower but as super
improvement as as as as again generative
generative of a new way of seeing things
of an improvement to our quality of life
or to our quality of thought so what I
hear in your questioning are a couple of
those things nuance really big big like
large-scale and you know generating a
positive outcome and I think that
reflects back what you said about the
quality of your life the quality of your
relationships the quality of your
conversations is reflected yeah I can I
can say another aspect to this is to of
course hang around people that also
really love these types of questions and
conversations and and execution so
actually bringing ideas into the world
and actually providing a service or a
product or some sort of value to people
I we get a little bit tired of just the
philosophy over and over again but when
you talk to somebody that actually has a
channel or has a product or has
something to bring in value that is
that's further indicative of their
ability to actually go and create into
the world as well yeah I was thinking
about one of the questions on your list
having to do with
with how the world's can I can't
remember the exact way it was
articulated but it was something like
what is there that we can do or what
changes what's the way what's the
pathway to changing equity in our
culture and to changing access in our
culture and one of the things that I
think I've seen over the course of my
living in Silicon Valley since 2000
right the last 18 years that I think
it's pretty obvious to many people but
the way I'd named it is a
disintermediation right the fact that we
have this liberated we have this
liberation in terms of our access to
send agates indicating our thoughts and
whether that's through these kind of
channels that were on right now or
podcasts or you know a variety of other
means that we can self publish our own
books that you know people can write
blogs and I I think that that access to
information and that ability to take our
thoughts forward into a product and to
reach many people is a huge contribution
to changing society and to you know to
to creating more equity yeah you I can't
believe you're already 18 episodes deep
you just started like three months ago
well I'm basically I'm committed to one
Episode a week one a week and partly
because it's you know starting anything
new is challenging and it's my belief
that I have to just practice keeping on
showing up and the beautiful thing about
podcasting for me is the opportunity to
learn and I love learning I love
learning new things and I love being
challenged and I love it's just a
perfect synergy for me and you know one
story I tell a little bit because it
relates to this idea that you just spoke
about about what does it mean to bring
ourselves out into the world to actually
not just have thoughts and I've been
giving a lot of thought to that because
and I'm going a little bit of a
circuitous route here but one of the
things that I see in particular culture
say I'm 53 and I think a lot about women
my age and the the the situation that
you know I I homeschooled my kids which
we could go into more detail about
definitely or go
go into the yes and particularly I don't
call it homeschooling but it meant being
very involved in my kids lives and in
fact I also co-founded a community of
people in the Bay Area who are taking
their kids out of brick-and-mortar
school for academic and intellectual
reasons so that they could actually get
their intellectual needs met and a
customized educational tract and so in
doing that that communities like 400
people now it's about 400 yeah it's over
400 we keep trying to trim it down to
people who aren't active and people who
aren't really in need of it so that it's
a very vibrant and engaged group but we
keep on growing because there's just a
lot of people who need and want access
to a community support environment where
they can take on a customized learning
journey for their kids and be supported
in it and there's no better place to do
that than the Bay Area anyway I'm so the
result what that community tends to
attract it tends to self-select for
families who are outside the box
thinking highly educated extremely
intelligent very involved in their kids
lives and willing to go an alternate
path and so as a result we have this
incredible breadth of parents mostly
mostly mothers but we have quite a few
fathers too who have spent now that are
now that the long tail age of the kids
is going into college and and they're
starting to age out where we're starting
to accumulate a number of people and
parents who spent the last 15 or 20
years or something around that 12 10
years really engaged in supporting their
kids education yeah and now they're
saying what do I do
and these are such vibrant and
intelligent people and they've for the
most part spent their time learning
alongside their kids yeah and one of the
missions that I have in the next five
years is to support people and bring
some of these amazing people together to
find what is that story that's yours to
tell and how do you bring it forth into
the world because there's a lot of
knowledge there's a lot of jewel there's
a lot of beauty and truth and power
sitting in that collective of people
whose stories need to be her
and one of my missions is how do we help
each other how do we band together how
do we have these kind of conversations
that are rich and deep and draw out in
each other the truth and the the truth
of our lives that needs to be told and
then the big question that you just
mentioned is how do we then take it out
to the world how do we serve it up how
do we how do we support each other in in
having it told there's all these
untapped jewels that are inside of
people it's so fascinating to think
about it on a meta level on a micro
level and that's the beautiful thing
right you could take one person and say
what's the what's the gold that needs to
be uncovered in this person or you can
look at it in a community and say this
community has so much rich richness in
it that needs to be peeled back and
presented and you know shared yeah so
yeah that's cool both on the individual
level and at the community level maybe a
family level maybe at a corporate level
maybe an organizational level
collective level there's all these tiers
even though this is our first
conversation my sense is that that is a
premise and a value that we share in a
recognition that we share I think I feel
like I see that in you and that almost
everything on every layer can be applied
at another layer yeah truth is
multi-layered and multi you know it's
like there's all kinds of places where
one if the truth exists one place it
probably exists somewhere else if you're
getting to the generalizable principle
yeah totally I love it good okay so
maybe we unpack a little bit more about
this on college movement because this is
very very fascinating I don't think
enough people are even aware that but
let me I'll do a little chime on
something that we talked about on the
show and then you can follow through on
it you keep drinking coffee so we speak
a lot about the importance of the parent
to the child has the child's being
birthed into the world we even reference
the parent as the deity of the child as
in you are the one
is responsible fully for the education
of the child there are there is of
course community help they're supposed
to be teachers and mentors and other
people but the parent is this sort of
main foundational pillar of trying to
open up the child to new ways of
thinking to experiencing the world to
having joy in the world to feeling all
these different emotions so we think
about it from the perspective of how
could you how could we possibly be
totally okay with the current state of
the education system it's good it's it's
done a good job but there's there are
things that it's like missing this
little piece to every child that's being
printed into the world it's like a
little chip on the shoulder and is that
is that little chip that's missing is
that maybe understanding the cosmos
understanding evolution understanding
their heart their brain understanding
their spirituality maybe understanding
morality why are the or why are we not
maybe universally collectively teaching
a couple principles like that so so now
this whole like um college this whole
alternative educational movements coming
into play where where we have we have
these parents and these in these schools
that say that actually we think that
it's good to potentially take people
take kids out of the current school
system and maybe try other things ways
that might mold their minds better into
the world I think that's a really
interesting way to to move forward Ron
I'm still on the parent being a deity
thing where you just assume that all
parents are doing a good job in regards
to that I'm just playing devil's
advocate speaking on behalf of you know
young people that may want to learn and
may want to be critical thinkers and may
not want to conform to a society that's
sick where a parent would instill that
discipline on them to do just that I'm
what's a parent is do anything I'm not
really quite understanding what you mean
it's a god the parent is like I
understand God but what do you mean
parent says God meaning the parent is
the all-powerful person in their life
and in their education and
it is that is that ideal or not ideal is
that the query like parent has God in
terms of emotional attachment or I'm not
really sure can you say bit more Shh so
the idea of that is that I mean imagine
birthing a child into the world and then
just being like totally okay for me not
to educate this child as a majority of
the child's education into the world I I
feel like that is a not an okay thing to
do you you birth the child into the
world
Tarzan worked out fine are you like a
nun a school oriented person I'm
schooler
yeah like God explained that so let's so
let me try to jump in here in some of
these pieces cuz there's a lot to talk
about in what you said like you just you
just like open a little Pandora's box
for me we do that for each other so so
the idea of unschooling
is one premise towards learning outside
of a traditional brick-and-mortar school
and it's an it's a particular approach
to homeschooling and I'd love to talk
about why I don't use the word
homeschooling because for me it's not
relevant but one of the approaches to
learning outside of brick-and-mortar
school is called unschooling and that's
when you trust that the kids are natural
learners and if left to their own
devices and left to their own curiosity
with their curiosity intact and with
interesting information strewn about
them in their lives and exposing them to
things they will do a better job of self
educating and learning themselves than
they could possibly get in school so
there that also exists on a continuum
there's radical on schooling where
people people you know I'm interpreting
it but where it's really allowed you can
do whatever you want you want to play
video games all day I trust that you're
gonna find a way to either learn from
that and maybe grow past it and I you're
you're all on your own and it's all good
but there's a continuum so that's one
aspect so I'm wondering if what you mean
by the parent as deity I'm wondering how
that fits in because then yeah when you
were thinking first year that child is
this in the world yeah the child's
helpless yes okay yes so you nurture
that child after the first year and then
in the second year then in the second
year are you going back to work nine to
five for five days a week and not being
there with your child while they learn
to walk they learn language they learn
all these different mobile skills all
those things well why not be there with
your child maybe we maybe even progress
culture to in a way that that brings the
parent more into the child's life and
then okay you're getting to a really hot
button for me right now
big time pet peeve hot button yes
exactly like we live in a culture that
does not honor the fact that parents are
critical parenting is one of the most
important oh you're know you're exactly
my point
I just try and say let's think of a
better word right now yeah what what is
what's the word so I had a guest on my
show last week if that hasn't aired yet
and her name is Syl Reynolds and she and
her daughter Eliza do coursework called
they have a book called mothering and
doddering where doddering is an active
verb that the role daughter is important
so we were talking on my show about the
fact that this term this term and I
actually did a talk not too long ago on
the fact of what's the idea of
helicopter parenting right so helicopter
parenting is this term that is basically
laid on parents who were involved in
their kids as a criticism of involvement
because we live in a culture that
essentially says that essentially
promotes that that there should be this
rugged individualism and kids we should
get them to it as quickly as possible
right like get them in their own room
get them handling it's a very deeply
steeped in our culture idea of in recent
generations that people should be
individual like rugged individuals from
the time they're like five you know and
I just don't believe that so anyway when
we taught when I talked with with with
SIL I raised this point about the fact
that helicopter parenting is a term that
I feel is a little bit
used to kind of like abused parents who
were involved and sort of to dismiss the
importance of it because we live in a
culture that dismisses the importance
and the impact and the profound need of
effective parenting for the most part
let's unpack that just a little bit more
and say that there are crazy helicopter
parents that write the college entrance
essays and stuff so so her point was
this and I totally agree with her there
are they're very rare they're very rare
I mean I I think that is extra I think
that is an idea that is promoted by
people who I don't even know why they
would promote it because involved
parenting scares people maybe because
it's a lot of responsibility because
there's a lot that you give up when
you're an involved parent for sure maybe
there was a better way than explaining
it via helicopter maybe there was she
took this metaphor I thought and said
and she said you know what I don't think
helicopter parents are very common she
said the way I like to think about it is
as a helicopter pad because parents can
be helicopter pads and that's the place
where where we're supporting because
parenting is about scaffolding to me
it's about working on our own selves to
be the best people we can be and
supporting and nurturing our kids along
the way to increasingly help them to
become individualized and autonomous and
effective and safe and listen I I know
means got it all worked out
you know parenting if nothing else is a
vast experiment that goes on and on you
never really quite know how it's gonna
work out scaffolding and principles are
pretty good things to have so what are
these principles is that what we were
also referencing in our in our
conversation and that is kind of what
whether you want to call it a helicopter
pad or whether you want to call it being
the sole one that's first and foremost
responsible for the education of the
child
what are these sort of scaffolding what
are these basic principles that parents
should be teaching kids though again the
big should o kids know there are
definitely some things there are some
things you don't want your kid to not
understand evolution that's probably not
beneficial to society you probably don't
your kid to think that the earth is flat
or that the things like that okay so
you're talking about content right now
and my inclination is always towards
meta learning and I know you know we we
talked a little bit about that now and
my idea of meta learning was evolved or
started I started to think about it more
when I was actually at a home schooling
conference and there's this thing at
this California homeschool conference
where they put a panel at kids who've
been homeschooled and then parents peel
them with questions because all the
parents anxieties and fears about are my
screwing up my kid by homeschooling come
out and they ask you know did you get
into college what was your experience of
college and then one year I was there
someone asked what's the best thing you
got from homeschooling and this girl on
the panel is about 18 or 19 said the
best thing I got from homeschooling was
the ability to know and the knowledge
that no matter what it is I want to
learn I know how to go about learning it
and to me that's meta learning right so
to me it doesn't really matter whether I
apply my kid with the idea about
evolution but in an ideal world I'm
raising someone who's excited about
learning who knows how to ask questions
who knows how to find answers who is
self-aware who is able to communicate
effectively in a variety of means who
you know those kind of things right so
if you matter the principles the
scaffolding then is meta linking is meta
learning this these of these principles
critical thoughts communication learning
knowing how to learn whatever you want
self-awareness but there doesn't it help
to not believe that the earth is flat
okay what doesn't it help to not believe
that but why would someone believe the
earth is flat because they are ignorant
but I mean if you raise a kid you okay
you've just given birth to a kid right
you've you're feeding it your kid in my
kid is much more in danger of being
having propaganda my propaganda then the
earth is flat propaganda because my kid
is and I'm not and I'm not
therefore like I'm just kind of look
the opposing side you think you're gonna
have a kid and you're gonna feed it and
put it to bed at night and read it
stories and then get it up the next
morning and take it to your to your
recording studio and then the kids
suddenly gonna believe the earth is flat
well think about the kid walks in the
studio and goes oh there's a globe over
there I don't think your kids gonna
think the earth is flat now the kid is
more at risk we're not talking about
mica we're talking about kids in general
okay so we're talking about if a kid in
general across the planet is growing up
an ignorant state that's it's there it's
both their parent that then it needs to
take on some responsibility for not
helping that child learn about the earth
being round but also the metal learning
aspect to it is helping the child be a
critical thinker so that when they see a
piece of content on the internet that
says that the earth is flat or that
another piece of content that says
gravity doesn't exist or that or that
even even worse though is that maybe
something like all all X is bad or all Y
is good
so this vast generalization of promotion
of some sort of value you know maybe all
peace is good or all that kind of stuff
but I'm getting at this point of what is
the scaffolding for raising children
into the world across the planet yeah
that's the question what are these best
principal ok so I'm gonna just take it
back a little bit to I think what you're
hittin on like I was gonna be flip right
I'd say you're really asking how do I
make sure that kids are raised within
education that's consistent with what I
believe right I'm I would argue and say
not what I believe but rather than what
all seven and a half billion people
collectively want to progress to we had
don't have global conversations about
that yeah it's not about me it's about
us okay yeah so would you is it too
simple is it too much of a
simplification to say that you might be
talking about those meta learning skills
that have to do with critical thinking
yeah just those all the all the meta
learning skills critical thinking
occation all
these skills that you listed earlier
that being a scaffolding for a child to
be race into the world what are the how
what are the best practices for parents
to help do it and if parents don't have
the time where that kind of stuff who
are the best teachers or who are the
best mentors around or communities
around that can help do that for the
child yeah that's a really it's a really
interesting and big question and we
finally got there
yeah and there's a part of me that
thinks that the cream just rises to the
top and let me just say that out loud
for a second I might disagree with
myself in a second but there's a part of
me that believes this disintermediation
piece the fact that we have access to so
much information I'd like to believe
that that gives us exposure in ways that
forces us to grapple with thinking and
that our natural inclination is to be
curious and to seek truth and truth and
I mean like I've used that really
lightly because I'm kind of like I'm
kind of a big subjectivist like I just
I'm not sure there's a truth but and so
there's a part of me that really really
would like to see that and I see
illustrations of that not being the case
in our world right now so that's where I
I take pause I say wow I'm not really
sure what the answer is because you do
see so much divisive nough sand so much
polarization and the thing that occurs
to me is that before we even get to
getting to the same truth and making
sure that people are you know not living
in under a veil of ignorance because
they're believing the world is flat or
whatever else there's a part of me that
feels what you said earlier when we were
talking about earlier about how you ask
questions and how you answer them that's
actually the critical piece and that is
how do we depolarize ourselves right in
and of ourselves how do we depolarize
our own ideas how do we look beyond one
belief that we have and then see the
nuance underneath it or even look at it
from a dialectical point of view right
how do we
take seemingly opposing ideas whether
they're mine and yours or mine within
myself and grapple with them to see all
those layers of nuance and to interact
with our thoughts on that way and then
how do we help other people to do the
same thing yeah so how do we create an
environment that's the the real question
to me isn't so much how do we make sure
that people aren't living you know
ignorant thoughts living out and rots
are being taught ignorant thoughts but
how do we nurture ourselves and our in
each other and our own children because
it's my belief that that's where we have
to start I really do believe that we
have to start with ourselves like it's
like it's getting to the point where
it's a cliche but there's a deep truth
in it right and so for me the query is
how do i how do i explore my own
thinking so that I don't live in a
polarization like live in a polarization
of my own thoughts so you get what I'm
saying yeah so and I don't know what the
answer is because I think we have a long
way to go as human beings and I think
that we one of the challenges for us as
human beings is that our human nature is
we want to put ourselves on a side of an
idea of a team of a species of a and we
want to like that's where we're
comfortable that's our natural
inclination and at the same time we want
to merge like these there's these
opposing human inclinations that we are
consistently grappling with and to me
the question is how do we keep on doing
this dance in a way that's productive
and maybe just doing the dance is the
generative piece you know maybe being in
the conversation is the answer maybe
exploring the nuances is a step in the
right direction I don't know it is it is
the notion of knowing how to have an
outstanding conversation a conversation
that is a quantum astons
thought-provoking not as little bias as
possible all that good stuff
I would agree that tuning into one's own
being and being able to uncover that and
bring that to the world is one of the
crucial pillars of what we're getting at
and I would continue to argue that the
scaffolding that
children are raised on it is also a
crucial pillar of the conversation as
well so those so how would you do it
what would you do knowing that we're in
agreement about scaffolding as an
important process the art of outstanding
conversations as well right okay so so
from a pragmatic point of view given
that we're in agreement that scaffolding
is the role parents play and hopefully
the role teachers whatever teachers are
involved play right
it's not about delivering the content or
shoving content down like that's that's
last century right so given that we're
in agreement with that how would you
implement what would you change in the
world so that there was more
implementation of scaffolding or metal
learning or the kind of skill sets that
you think would make this for this kind
of difference what changes would you
make look I do like the premise of
unschooling I do like that I've seen
some efforts in Scandinavia where they
take children into forests and they let
the kids play outdoors and the forests
and they get to go and explore the mud
and the twigs and the insects and the
branches and the oxygen out there is
fresh and yeah all that good stuff and
they get to do actual physical exercise
practice motor skills love stuff like
that it's completely different from even
just recess on concrete so just
completely different and then Ron what
was the other thing we were talking
about yesterday we were talking about
[Music]
yesterday
who else that day that other spin in
regards to one that up in regards to
child education where we had another one
there was another point with Robert
I think Robert Robert Griffith well what
else was he mentioning about childhood
education around the world there was
another good one all I remember is his
flower reference the way his flower
recognized the most beautiful thing you
know there was a maybe there was a
did have to do with that but okay so
other aspects of the scaffolding that
could be put into place some sort of
base morality thou shalt not kill
Wow okay morality morality is such an
interesting one to me then thou shalt
not kill thy earth is round there's
really such argumentative points that we
can't just no no no I don't think they
are I don't but I mean I think I'm
thinking of it more from the larger
piece not so much from the detail like
okay and we're just keeping going back
to the earth is round the earth is flat
because it's just a simplification er
it's an example right that we can but
the real question is to me is I'm
fascinated by this now flat-earthers
Twitter what does that mean you'll see
you'll see right here the flat earth
also we'll pull it up and I'll show it
to you okay all right Rhett Ron are you
on the middle Kim can you pull this in
on the middle cam please on which one
the PTZ okay zoom in on that please Flat
Earth Society tell them how many
followers they're encouraging the spread
of ideas and free thoughts since 1865
read the facts visit us at the org 147
almost 48 thousand followers they these
are people who believe that the earth is
a globe because they saw a car in space
on the internet oh my gosh
we believe any privately how come okay
[Laughter]
if I may you know when you ask the
question later are we in a simulation
not not to speak on yes not just in
defense of these flat earthers but if
such is the case that this is a
simulation then you know there it's
possible that you know there's it's
round it is
it's multi-dimensional you know I'm not
speaking in their defense but this whole
3d reality your more subjective thinker
you had mentioned earlier so I'm a
little more objective myself that's I'm
just saying it's totally cool to have
again I'm just trying to fold what are
the objective scaffoldings for kids
growing up thou shalt not kill thy earth
is round die has a heart that beats a
hundred thousand times a day to power
your body I mean these are objective
thoughts there's no such thing as I'm
teaching my child their heart only beats
a thousand times a day no that's not how
it works
you know that's not how it works so what
would you do to change it
I mean are you are you a proponent of do
you think if it was possible to go into
one of those houses and saying we're
taking these kids no no no not like that
yeah I can't it can't be some [ __ ]
militaristic that'd be [ __ ] up beyond
belief military's breaking down the door
you ignorant [ __ ] give me your
children so it's more like okay how do
we actually promote objective truth or
yeah yes so here's here's an interesting
example
why is there no sort of let's call it up
a book yeah a book for the zero year-old
a book for the one-year-old a book for
the two-year-old work we're not
specifically saying that every single
child has to be folded into this mold
and that they all have to blah blah blah
all this that's not the essence of the
point that sense of the point is to say
that if the heart beats a hundred
thousand times a day just [ __ ] teach
the kid that it beats a hundred thousand
times a day okay and and and then and
then if the if the earth is round just
just teach them that the earth is round
and then there's no arguing that there's
no arguing gravity there's no arguing
the molecular structure of water there's
no arguing that your brain is the is the
thing that enables you to
process reality there's just no arguing
these things now is they're arguing
immigration and health care and economic
systems and political systems yes there
totally is and and that's and that's
great but there are certain things that
children should be should be taught into
the world and and if we want to say I'm
a nihilist and there's no meaning or
purpose to life I'm not gonna push my
thoughts onto other people they can
raise their way however they want that's
a valid perspective go with that
perspective in life I think that if you
want to eradicate suffering as much as
you want to eradicate ignorance that
those two things go hand in hand then
that then we really need to have this
sort of you know I've really been
enjoying this term like wisdom 2.0 or
whatever these people are now starting
to say there's the super power use the
wisdom 2.0 is these free thought
projects all these kind of things
what are they coalesce into as the
scaffolding and why can't we get along
together why can't China provide Africa
can provide South America Europe why
can't they provide other aspects to this
scaffolding that the United States and
Western philosophy doesn't
for example Western philosophy gives a
[ __ ] about meditation now pretty much
it's just recently as meditation
becoming a even an even an entry level
meditation 101 is now starting to
permeate through Thank You headspace and
calm and yeah and these types of
services because people can't even
meditate without a [ __ ] smartphone
that is that is so [ __ ] the [ __ ] in
the first place but look at look out
east look onto the eastern hemisphere on
the planet
Asia would look at the west and say that
the reason why you have conspicuous
consumption the reason why you have
greed and power hierarchies that are
corrupt is [ __ ] the reason why you have
a political system that's absolutely in
gridlock and wanting to polarize the
[ __ ] out of every single issue is
because people and Swami Ananda was on
our show explaining this super well is
people don't know how to practice inner
man
and if you learn how to practice in our
management not only do you become
actualized but then you beat the society
becomes actualized and then we don't
have these problems that we have in the
West in many ways so something that's
been practiced for thousands of years
thousands of years the ignorance of a 25
year old running around on the streets
saying that I don't need to practice
meditation I can find my own way to
enlightenment
listen thousands of years of practice of
figuring out the human experience and
you think you can just your little speck
of sand can just go and figure it out
yourself no you should practice what has
the genius that has been taught the
wisdom that has been taught down the
years this is why you go to Tony Robbins
for for self actualization this is why
you go to Neil deGrasse Tyson for
Astrophysics knowledge this is why you
go to a people like my gosh there's so
many global leaders across all these
different industries but you know these
are people that have practiced the
wisdom of their industry and the
dissemination of their of their wisdom
and and even the ones thousands of years
you don't look at a cup you don't look
at a cup and go oh this cup I don't need
to use cups you don't say that [ __ ] you
know why because cups are brilliant
invention thousands of years ago okay so
yeah so I love that you I love that you
you know are bringing back to this idea
of self-awareness right because that
sort of consistent with what I'm saying
before which is we don't need to start
with how do we change other people's
ideas we need to practice our own inner
self awareness I mean you said it in
such a beautiful way very articulate and
you know perfect and earlier you said
that what we one of the answers is to go
to nature right and that seems like an
age old and true experience that helps
us connect with our intern Eicher and
with our with our experience in the
world and is like this sort of
experience of ourselves as
as physical beings and to me the
question I have to questions when you
were talking one of them was one of them
was where does our responsibility to
change these things that we see these
problems that we see so where does it
where does our responsibility to change
other people to change all these
ignorant Fox right where's our
responsibility to that end including my
own ignorance right it's my
responsibility to fix my own ink so
that's what I was really trying to say
right is that how do I keep myself from
falling into my own biases and to living
out my belief systems as they are
polarized and to adding more you know of
the binary into the binary you know
there's there's a line at Popeye's or at
chick-fil-a and you and you walk through
the line and you say do you know that a
million chickens are slaughtered per
hour in the United States probably not
they probably don't know and they
probably don't really care and they
don't care if the chickens are pumped
with human growth hormone if they're fed
[ __ ] if they're caged they don't really
care about those things because humans
care about the survival of their flesh
vehicles so they just need to put
something in their mouth so that it
powers their body yeah and well let
different layers of actualization
depending on where your focus is right
but but even the general like okay as
long as you know yeah
the chickens might be in humanely raised
there's billions of them slaughtered
across the world then if you know those
things and you still choose to do it
then that's your choice but if you have
never been taught about those things
then you might not even be aware of
what's going on in the food supply chain
that's getting the actual stuff to you
so I first and foremost it's our
responsibility to go inward manage thy
own inner self and inspire thyself to
learn and to care about learning and
that and the boulder of ignorance is
strapped to all of our ankles is like
the it's like a square kilometer when
when we're born and then like we have to
chip away at it with a pickaxe our whole
life just a little
tiny bits our whole life and then
eventually if you are like 40 or 60 or
80 and you've gotten that kilometer
square sized Boulder down to like a
hundred meters squared
that's pretty [ __ ] good and then you
can disseminate a lot of that wisdom to
other people in the world and if you're
if you're with their with the pickaxe
what how can you upgrade your tool to be
a freaking like excavator that can
tackle out that Boulder versus like
maybe like one pin you're trying to pin
at it it's very small like a little
microscopic shovel or something there's
these dude what what is your tool at
excavating that Boulder of ignorance as
well so I I love how we've gotten down
here I really think this has been one of
my favorite conversations I'm happy that
we're going back and forth and work yeah
so we're so free-spirited you're super
articulate I just really appreciate the
metaphors you're using and the depth
you're going into and the passion that
you're talking about these ideas with
and honestly you asking some really
great questions and I'm my brain is just
going in so many different directions
and I'm trying to try to trying to
integrate and I love that place it's a
great place to be thank you the tennis
match can't be played without the other
person on the other side that's hitting
the ball back and that's adding their
own unique thoughts to it the new
analogies and metaphors that are really
helping this conversation come to life
so okay are we wrapping up now let's see
if we can because I have to ask you
before we wrap up at some point we have
to talk about what your superpower is
that's right so I think part of the
superpower is the insatiable curiosity
yeah that's that's part of the
superpower
I really don't I don't take time very
lightly I take I take time as problem as
the most valuable commodity that exists
here dying every second yeah and so to
leverage every second to for growth is
amazing so I choose to do that so if I
do have a spare moment to do something
like learn I will either you know for
example here's a good here's a good at
hopefully this resonates yeah you you're
you know I was just eating a falafel
pita yesterday from the flying falafel
next door amazing place we got to get
them as patrons so so I'm eating that
and for the first chunk of it I was just
really absorbed into the moment of the
beauty of the food and of the taste of
the food on my tongue and as I was
swallowing it and digesting it was just
absorbed into that process I was really
grateful for that whole process then I
was like okay I've eaten quite a bit of
the falafel how about I opened up a
video that I want to watch to me that is
one of the key turn points of your life
is valuing time and then realizing what
we are using our time for so as I open
up YouTube all of my recommended videos
are pretty much global leaders
disseminating knowledge and the videos
that I watched were the the ex-president
of Google China speaking about
artificial intelligence I mean in this
particular moment particular moment yeah
so I watched that for like three minutes
and then I think Ron and ELISA came in
through the door so I you know stopped
watching videos at that time but that's
a little example of you know what what
are you watching
when you click on the YouTube or the
Netflix or whatever us whatever it is so
insatiable curiosity yeah time not
taking time lightly really really
understanding moment to moment that
death is coming and not only should I be
learning as much as possible but I
should also be wanting to bring as much
value and impact and flourishing to the
world yeah
there's something in your superpower
that I'm seeing that has to do with both
of those things but some kind of
integration having to do with I have
like this feeling of like exploding
things like not like blowing things up
in a positive way it's almost like I
feel like you're throwing at you your
the sense I get and you know this is
really the first in-depth conversation
we've had yeah please could it be like
there's this whole carpet is just filled
with Legos like little LEGO pieces yeah
and then there's like viewers that are
watching the LEGO pieces and then I just
like dig up a couple LEGO pieces a piece
them together throw them out there for
like a vision and like people are like
whoa look at how those LEGO pieces are
arranged yeah that works but I also I
see it as like being a little more
vibrant than that and a little more
integrated ya know it's exactly what I
was gonna say fireworks is actually the
explosion that I'm imagining like I
think you're an exploder you're an
exploder of ideas because there is
something that I really get from you
that has to do with really dynamic you
know there's a big piece that's not just
not you're not evolving ideas your
insatiable curiosity is creating
explosive you know fireworks something
like that you know it's not really the
way I usually think about superpowers
but there's something something like
that that's really uh your brain is
really interesting Thank You X I really
appreciate that my again the tennis
matches are only as good as the possibly
seriously is useless to just be sitting
here and going blah blah blah because of
that that is just it's nowhere near as
powerful in my opinion I really like
dialogue between two people yeah the
thing that I love about it is there
there's so many things that I still feel
oh these open threads that I'm feeling
like okay but what's the answer to this
other piece you know there's something
for directions that could still go so
without without getting very constantly
just just wanting to like give each
other hella love all the time I
recognize I recognize you recognizing me
and I really appreciate that because it
it's it's it's actually quite rare it's
one of my superpowers for sure thank you
thank you for recognizing it and I would
like to then reply and return that just
to shear way that we can converse and
laugh and be together is really cool and
it requires a special person to also be
able to do that with so I feel you and
I'm totally happy that you are unpacking
these firework explosions that are
occurring on both the super power you
podcast but as well as the two other
explorations of your life especially
with meta learning and helping with on
college and I really think that that's a
powerful thing that you've brought
together 400 families to be yeah
thank you out this you know I think the
one thing I would want to say to that no
want one thing it's the interesting
thing there are many things but that
process of bringing together those
families is part of a larger piece for
me which again when I look at what are
this what are the strengths that I have
or what is the way my life is generating
and default evolving and unfolding is it
really has to do with larger principles
and that is the larger principle of
freedom and autonomy collectivity and
community and there's another one
something like I don't know change
evolution something like that
so the the piece like I'm not that
involved there are lots of other people
running that group now and I'm super
happy that it exists because it's really
needed for people to come together and
to explore what that means to have
autonomy outside but the thing is the
the primary value is
we're what are the ways that we can come
together to create community and
collectivity so that we can actually
live autonomous free lives where we're
expressing ourselves in the best way we
possibly can and so that operates in
other ways in my life too but the other
thing I will also want to say is when
you when you when you just reflected me
back to me and experience of being here
I really felt it and I think that that
is a meta experience of what we're
talking about right like how can we
actually member stations between people
yeah like how can we actually just sit
here together and explore these abstract
ideas that are interesting and useful
and powerful but then when it comes
right down to it how can we just be
connected and feel yeah each other and
it's beautiful where did I see this oh
you're guys you're two guys that was
such a beautiful video yes this is human
connection to you in connection and
that's where that's where we can start
yeah even if we can't change those flat
earthers so we we went through the
scaffolding I think that's a lot of what
your meta learning pushes about is the
scaffolding which is great we talk about
that a lot we have the superpower you
link in the description for the builds
check out let's let's walk you through a
couple of our questions I would I would
like to hear your thoughts okay at least
give me an idea about what you think
about this sort of globalization that's
occurring how does the u.s. collaborate
with China with Russia with Africa as it
develops how do we work together ask me
a different one yeah like that question
come from like that's definitely not my
like I I'm grateful for the fact that we
are all needed because every and this is
where it comes right down to my
superpower I think you're answering the
question right maybe I'll answer it in a
meta way right but the thing is when it
comes down to it we are all needed and
there are people out there who no no
maybe they don't even know what the
answers are but they're engaged in the
question enough that they can influence
it and I'm not that
so try another one out okay how about
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world oh wow well I mean
what kind of already touching on it for
me the some of the most beautiful things
in the world have to do with connection
and human experience that's shared and
community and change and growth yeah and
you know like it's a little bit
redundant to maybe to our conversation
but it's essentially the truth for me
and there is nothing to me more
beautiful and in some ways more elusive
and especially as our world goes the
direction it's going right now in that
and I think that's one of the things
that is interesting about your question
some of the questions that I was looking
at and I'm thinking about is how do we
go the direction that we're going
technologically and maintain our
presence in our connection with
ourselves and with each other and I was
really fascinated by the fact when I
watched some of your videos how you're
engaged in both of those queries at the
same time and again that's that
dialectical for me right and that's the
dance that's beautiful to me is how do
we take these opposing human forces
whether they're you know HEI in the
development of you know the singularity
and where things are going
technologically and are we going to get
to the place where we can upload our
brains and live forever and that kind of
scientific challenge and then the other
side of the coin which is our very human
experience that exists in nature in the
moment and how the hell do we integrate
those on a day-to-day level in a
practical way and have them coexist in
our own lives and I guess what I would
say is that
beautiful and elusive dance is a
beautiful practice of being human yeah
so yeah that's an answer I guess that's
good and I you know that query for me is
just such a profound one like how do we
how do we how do we live in the future
world that's coming and not lose our our
humanity yeah oh that's a good question
that that needs to be added to our
simulation was the question it's
probably just the next step of humanity
where would no longer be humans but the
next thing that's just as good even I
just I don't so many of our
conversations go towards so getting rid
of the flesh vehicle or the meat puppet
and moving on to a digital consciousness
think about that I'm sorry I just I we
talked about that and you know we we
don't yet know how it's gonna work but
it's also very fascinating to think
about it it's crazy to think about it's
crazy I mean I'm I'm really mind blown
by it and I'm really triggered by it -
I'm super triggered by it
it's just so funny huh Silicon Valley
just has this concentration of these
conversations yeah you know and there
are other places in the world that have
these concentrations of conversations as
well but the network effect here is just
it's gone crazy yeah I was thinking
about this earlier but you could
probably double all of the rent prices
even though they're already so [ __ ]
high you could probably still double the
rent prices let's say one and a half
times them and people in San Francisco
would still figure out a way to earn
enough money to be able to live here to
pay the rent because they care so much
about the network effect yeah the
culmination of all of these ideas and
all these diverse people and all that
kind of stuff is just crazy
so landlords that are listening please
we will take a 50 percent royalty on
that idea just kidding but you know what
just to add into that everything
everything swings right and when I see
people increasingly looking at living in
communities because
they need to as a direct result of where
we're rent prices are going I feel that
that's or I see people developing things
like camp grounded where they're asking
people in their 30s to say hey let's
leave our technology at home and
reground ourselves in nature yeah that's
part of the digital detox the digital
detox thing and that focus as well as
like I say people living in communities
this is something that it's not new but
I think it's potentially going to grow
and become a lot more prevalent in
Silicon Valley out of necessity and I
think that's a beautiful a wonderful
thing yeah this whole nuclear family
thing and I've been and lived in one
I've been fighting it you know by having
other people living my house and couch
surfers and lots air B&B and building
communities but this whole thing about
these isolated small nuclear nuclear
families we live in is it's not ideal
and so in some ways it's the negative
things that you know burthen the new the
new layer of positive oh you're so right
we just had a Roman on the show young
Polsky AI safety and security professor
researcher and author and he
specifically talks about how all of the
fuck-ups that AI has are the reasons why
we just go and start making it more safe
and secure right there might be a really
bad oh in the future but I have to watch
that episode is that we were telling
about what it is this is also very
applicable to what we see outside of our
door yeah as in like a half times the
readiness more homeless people so
there's it's it's very applicable to
what we see happening yes and to figure
it out as a difficult complex process
and I'm very inspired to work with other
leaders around the world to try and make
it work another question for you is what
is something that you believe to be true
that nobody else really believes to be
true nobody else we're very very few
people well okay
I will answer that in the in with regard
to the what I live in right so again
we're in Silicon Valley and I I'm
surrounded by people who are oriented
towards ending aging and I'm grateful
for it I think it's a really worthy
process my husband is one of them and I
used to host the quantified self Silicon
Valley group for many years so I'm
surrounded by people who are interested
in bio hacking and optimizing our aging
and even go so far as to say we can end
you know we can we can extend human life
to into into you know forever and I
think you said you're gonna have our B
degree on your show and you know he's
won and and so I have this again this
challenge between recognizing this
pursuit it's a worthy pursuit in some
ways and in other ways I think it is a
disservice to us as human beings
tell us why well I think that there's an
egocentricity to the idea that we should
live together and I know all of the
Silicon Valley brains can give me all
kinds of logical reasons why I'm wrong
and why it doesn't make sense but I do
feel and I've been thinking about this a
lot more as I recently lost my mom to
cancer and I see you know aging as
something that you know and I'm not
saying losing my mom to cancer was
beautiful it was not it was extremely
painful but there's a part of the stages
of life that I think are our obsession
with youth and what living forever gets
in the way of us actually experiencing
so I think that there is a sort of a
tension between the natural wisdom that
we can develop if we go through the
stages of our lives in the most natural
way and we end up with the wisdom of
each stage because each stage has this
incredible beauty right and some of the
later ones the possibility in later
stages of aging come come from the
inclination to create this space for the
next generation of people and if our
focus is all on how do we
forever then I feel that in some ways
were missing that vital and beautiful
possibility of putting our attention on
the next generation and so I don't want
to go so far as to say that I don't I
believe completely differently again I'm
back to how do we resolve these
seemingly opposing ideas right how do we
pursue extending human life and live an
exquisite life in the face of our own
death and how do we embrace death and
aging as part of our inevitable process
and how can they all live together I
just sometimes feel that our youth
centered focus on our culture's focus on
youth and retaining youth actually costs
us some of our some of the wisdom that
we might otherwise land in you know I
was thinking about the fact that if you
were to you know if I was to ask you
here let me ask you the question
actually if you could live to be a
hundred and ten if you could we're
having to fight your way through it
versus living dying at 80 peaceful and
happy about it and happy with your life
which would you choose
I mean obviously the idea I guess is I
mean you haven't let you answer but
obviously you can live to be a hundred
and ten and peacefully die when you're
hundred ten that's the ideal right it
wasn't a very well articulated question
[Music]
of a life of more suffering but thirty
more years or less suffering I mean the
suffering is not something that the
people who are after extending life
they're very clear that what they're
after is extending house you mentioned
that you mentioned the stages yeah yeah
I really enjoyed that because there are
there is this uniqueness to being a
child and just being this like
absorption of all the environment and
then there's this uniqueness of being 18
and being like what do I do with my life
and there's this uniqueness of being
like 26 and just like hustling and then
there's this uniqueness of being like
thirty-five and wanting to have kids
having kids and then there's this
uniqueness of being like 45 yeah and
then when you start I think 40 around
that stage is when you start to look at
what is it gonna mean for you to start
you start to see in your your aging
years and then you start to think I mean
I think it starts to change a little bit
as our lifespan extends right that's the
are you me
that's the guy who I don't know if
you're what you're if you're referring
to the same one I am but there's the guy
who did the these stages and they're
almost map onto what you talked about so
it may be the same one he ended at 60 if
we just double from 80 to 160 yeah you
just double potentially double the span
of things and all of each phase of life
but also the only way to get to 160 is
by living healthier with less disease I
already have disease accumulating in my
25 year old body and that is very
frustrating for me to think about
because I don't even want the 13 year
old to be accumulating disease in their
body yeah so what's the best way to do
that is to make tweaks along the way
over time at the first sign of the
pathology go in there and tweak but if
we do that then maybe somebody that is
50 actually doesn't have any signs of
aging yet which is crazy to think about
because then they can go and do what
they want I think I mean I think they're
two different pieces I think that's a
great thing if we can if we can get rid
of disease and just kind of like I'm my
hips killing me right now cuz you know
my right is blah blah blah so that would
be great but there's another part of it
that has to do with the psychological
experience of aging and aging well
psychologically and I think that when we
put too much focus on our bodies and on
carrying the disease in our bodies and
and there's good reason to do that but
sometimes I think it gets in the way of
our reverse of our cycle or
psychological aging in a healthy way and
in particular the thing that I'm trying
to say that I'm not saying very well is
that one of the stages that happens
whether it's 50 or 60 I don't know
around there is your focus goes a lot
more extensively towards other people
now I I would say that you're pretty
precocious and you're in your attention
on the external world and on other
people if you're only 25 I thought you
were actually a lot older than that
based on your thinking but I think for
most people going through general these
general stages of life that gets a lot
deeper partly I think when you start as
a result of starting to see your your
your death approaching yeah you know and
I don't think everybody has this
experience you do of the preciousness of
time and living fully in every moment
when they're 25 I think for a lot of
people it takes having a bit of a closer
brush with death yes you might be
unusual in that way I've had a couple
just helped me a lot baby so I'm glad
that you know we're seriously this last
bit has been equally as epic as the
first I just I we have to do number two
we do we have to make number two happen
at some point sounds good maybe I'll
figure out some of the answers to some
of those big hard you asked me if you
you know if you come in and ask me you
know another question about like what
makes a quality question I was fantastic
yeah we can we unpack that for you know
10 15 is just that question so I
definitely feel there's a lot more we
could talk about for sure yeah so come
let's both come in hot with some more
questions and we'll and then come on my
show too
yeah yeah exactly what can we can we not
take this yeah this will be this can be
an episode yeah and the podcast that
would be nice
we would love that and we would share
the out of it across all our platforms
so okay so this was incredible I'm super
great thank you me too
really really beautiful and lovely to
connect with you you turn your brain and
your heart your brain the 3d reality
that we live in we want to you know we
push and both give a shout out to Keith
Powers our friend yeah
connecting us just a really and and
patron sees patron of our project and
I'm clear when this is well their family
office just yeah it's it's amazing when
the really strong connections are made
between people when they have to feel
that it would be good so thank you so
much and and thank you everyone for
tuning and if you had a good time give
us a like comment below what you think
we'd love to hear from you or email in
simulation series at gmail.com give us a
subscribe share the content give you the
content to share we have so many topics
covered in this talk segments were
profound to go to that time stop and
copy the URL at that time and send it
off to people get them thinking about it
and talking about it more let's get more
of these interesting conversations going
on across the world support us on
patreon if you'd like we'd greatly
appreciate it we have a roof and
electricity and Internet and all these
other things that we need to cover so we
would love your help and support with
that all our equipment big shout out to
our partner producer Ron Vargas who's
always doing an incredible job back
there thank you so much and please check
out the superpower you podcast with Lisa
Betts little Bob thank you so much such
a pleasure thank you all right
you